meantime a new report has found
two-thirds of people are concerned about
the cost of Christmas dinner this year
amid the cost of living crisis a survey
by the Salvation Army also found almost
one in five people expect to use items
from a food bank this festive season can
you believe that let's speak now to
Lieutenant Colonel Fallon from the
Salvation Army with us here in the
studio hi Dean it's good to see you
thanks so much indeed for joining us on
the program this morning one in five
people using a food bank that's what our
server has shown and it mirrors what
we're seeing on the ground a huge
increase in the number of people coming
to us for food food parcels and and
other support and people who would never
have normally expected to come to the
Salvation Army we're seeing nurses
coming to our food banks we are seeing
people who are just saying I used to
donate to you thank you very much for
the support you can give and that's
great we want people to come but there
is an incredibly high level of anxiety I
think it's 80 percent of people over 65
are saying they're not sure how they can
afford Christmas dinner and so yes
there's a problem and there's also a
significant level of stress and worry
out there about about the economic
situation and personal finance because I
mean it's December this the
week you know Christmas is just a month
away and normally we get so excited
about Christmas you know all the family
around the table lots of presents under
the tree that's not going to be the case
for a lot of people no we I heard a
heartbreaking story recently of a man
who's been told by his family we can't
afford you to come this Christmas and he
was saying I'm going to stay home and I
think the message to people like that is
please don't stay at home there are
there are churches like the Salvation
Army there are Charities there are other
faiths who want to welcome you in and
we're also part of the warm welcome
campaign of saying to people if you want
a warm place to come a place where
you'll be welcome and be made to feel at
home come come to the Salvation Army or
come to to one of the other places
around the around the country so I think
we're trying to reach out to people but
also to thank people who are our
financial supporters who help us to do
this work because that's also difficult
for people at this time when everybody's
under economic pressure at the moment so
what do people do if they feel Under
Pressure they don't know what to do they
don't know they're being told not to go
to the family because they can't afford
them to be around the table how do you
help them what do you do so we partner
with other people the Salvation armies
in 600 places across communities across
the country with our churches and our
community centers we've also got a
network of lifehouses for people who are
homeless and so we reach out to the most
vulnerable people on the streets but we
like working Partnerships so in your
town in your city in your neighborhood
you'll find someone you'll find a church
you'll find a community group you may
find the Salvation Army go and talk to
them we're not McDonald's we don't do
everything the same across the country
but reach out and people really want to
connect with you and try and help
everybody through this Christmas season
what about people who say I'm not
religious I can't I can't ask for for
any help from the Salvation Army yeah we
we've been around 155 years and we look
after people irrespective of religion
and yes Christmas is a Christian season
and it's a celebration and we want it to
be joyful we want people to celebrate
the birth of Jesus but everybody is
welcome and and there's no pressure
um certainly you know there's a cup of
tea a bit of cake or whatever it is
you'll be very very welcome
going to food banks because I I know
from my own experience of you know
working in them people are embarrassed
and they don't want to do it yep
we really don't just want to hand out
food we want a relationship with someone
we want to try and find out how can we
help you know the Salvation Army's also
got Employment Services to help people
get work debt to help you if you've got
your financial problems so it's all
sorts of wrap around services or we can
refer you to other partners in in your
community who can help so I think it's
it's if you're facing difficulty it
might be that we can give you a
Christmas toy for your children this
year reach out see how we can work
together with you and and in a
partnership I think we can solve this
and people who want to support the
Salvation Army how do they do that our
website
salvationarmy.org.uk we've delighted to
receive donations thank you very much
okay it's good to see you Merry
Christmas maybe a little bit earlier
thank you nice to see you thank you very
much thank you